російські акції світло правки так звали
гуманітарної папери за ми ж Росія з
комору хіба дуальних операцій the
active пливу російських спецслужб на
території engine тримаючи
кремль продовжує простого в цій
пандемії змита посил і неполітичних
відписку по всьому світу чи в же діброві
будинок ще реальність ризикового контингенту
якийсь розум спокійний будемо розгоном до
росіянам у катували було за сера джона на
розвиток пропаганди формування
позитивного іміджу у росіян з падаючим
лобіювання мб це не ще до незрозумілих
санкцій це лиска спецоперація су
провалювалася по грозах і чи то з ним
медді за крима газеті la stampa я коли
звол особини аналіз так званої у
російської допомоги щодо давно росія
розгорнула силу інформації ну компанії
сюди треба його монетарне до буму і кому
української православної церкви
московського патріархату священик і яко
та bada
захвалив це кора нагору нагадай рахунок
церкви московського патріархату було
єдині з церкв я до стану коло так про
з приводу валу сиру дверям видування в
умовах карантину церкв з дорученням
заходимо у спайку із соціальної дистанції
масок.
на вилягання кремля адже правда
гумконвой для лаври
києво-печерська за чехова петрівна
апараті в рамках
гібридну агресію проти України
україна моя всім жвавості для
локалізації спала фу коронавірусу в тому
числі і в києво-печерській лаврі муську
об'єктовий характер акції свічки пробував
пропагандист брухт і ви просто не церкви
і гк релігій навашино до для до
стабілізації ситуації в Україні
таким чином на моя жадібних пристав
дозволить Україні of ресора з прямого ти
черв'яний гуманітарний конвой фактично в
центр столиці нашого поверху
[музика]